To change what our box plots look like, we just need
to adjust the Y axis. We can use the [UNKNOWN] parameter
inside of Q plot to do so. Here, I can set
the upper and lower limits. The lower limit will be 0
and the upper limit will be 1000. Now, you may or
may not have gotten a warning message here about removing data
points. When we use the ylin parameter, we're actually removing data
points from our calculations. So the original box plots that we have
might look slightly different from this. Another way to create the
same plot is to use the scale y continuous layer. So we
can use this same bit of code here and then just
close off our parenthesis. [UNKNOWN] the scale wide continuous layer, I can
set the limits to be between 0 and 1000. Running this
code, we can see that we get the same exact box plots.
What I want to draw your attention to, is the female box
plot. Notice how the top of the box is just below 250.
So this value might be around 200 or 230. But this
value might not be accurate for all of our data. When we
use the ylim paramater or the scale_y_continuous layer, we actually remove
data points from calculations. So a better way to do this is
to use the cord Cartesian layer to set the y limits
instead. So, we'll use the same bit of code and then instead
of adding scale wide continuous layer, we'll add the cored Cartesian layer.
And here I'll set the y limits from 0 to a 1000.
Notice how the top of the box has moved slightly closer to
250 for females. I'll explain this difference in more detail in the
next video. We'll also discuss what the top of the box means.
What the bottom of the box means. And what this black line means.